The Silence of the Lambs is undoubtedly
one of the most iconic horror films of
all time
but even diehard fans might not know
about the real-world research onset
pranking and bizarre costume choices
that went into its production here is
the untold truth of Hannibal Lecter's
finest hour
although Dino De Laurentiis bought the
rights to the name Hannibal Lecter when
his studio made 1986 his Manhunter the
very nature of the Beast kept other
filmmakers away for years it makes sense
after all a cannibal psychiatrist is a
tough sell for a movie that is until
Gene Hackman and Arthur Krim of Orion
Pictures teamed up to buy the rights
Hackman was originally interested in
directing and wanted to play Lecter at
the same time but he later dropped out
after his daughter read the book and
objected to the story's heavy violence
créme bought Hackman's half of the
rights and Jonathan Demi intrigued by
the unusual story signed on its director
Demi initially considered a number of
actresses to play Clarice Starling
including Michelle Pfeiffer meg Ryan and
Laura Dern but Jodie Foster who had just
won an Oscar for the accused lobbied
hard for the parts her grit talent and
intelligence shone through and
ultimately landed her the role for
Hannibal Lecter almost every single
prestige actor of the day was on the
table Sean Connery Robert De Niro and
Dustin Hoffman were all under
consideration by now of course it's
impossible to picture anyone but Hopkins
wearing that infamous Muslim when you
think of The Silence of the Lambs one of
the first images that likely pops to
mind is dr. Lecter in his iconic Mass
strapped to an upright stretcher in the
movie itself
he has been restrained to meet Catherine
Martin's mother so he can pass on the
information he's been withholding about
Catherine's kidnapper the grill over the
mouth allows him to speak and be heard
but not bite as he's often fond of doing
of course this provides the opportunity
for some striking imagery to The
Criterion Collection has released some
terrifying behind-the-scenes footage of
Hopkins trying on a number of different
masks before settling on the one that
appears on screen one example is modeled
after a baseball umpire mask another is
a full night's helmet that makes Hector
look more like a Monty Python character
than one of the most chilling killers of
yet another makes him look like a
beekeeper luckily the choice that ended
up on screen is perfectly horrible and
gives the audience the chance to stare a
little longer intellect errs hypnotic
peepers the majority of the Silence of
the Lambs is seen from Clarice
starlings perspective one of the most
haunting moments of the film however
happens through a very different pair of
eyes Katherine Martin the girl kidnapped
by Buffalo Bill is trapped in a well in
his home
up above Buffalo Bill himself applies
makeup and dances around his dressing
room in pretty much the creepiest way
you can possibly imagine
but this dance wasn't actually scripted
nor were some of bills adornments like
the tattoo on his chest screenwriter Ted
tally got quite a shock when he finally
saw these moments unfold on screen
Buffalo Bill actor Ted Levine who had
done copious research to develop the
character was so nervous to film this
scene that he actually took shots of
tequila to get through it but it all
paid off
producer Edward saxons said about
Levine's performance the scene took a
lot of courage it wasn't in the script
and for me it's a very moving scene it
identifies the pain and twisted
psychology of this character as anyone
who's seen this movie will know Buffalo
Bill is a doozy of a serial killer he
kidnaps women starves them and
eventually kills them all in an effort
to create a woman suit out of their skin
and it was the real-life Wisconsin
serial killer
Ed Gein upon whom psycho is also based
who served as the inspiration for
Buffalo Bills particular obsessions Ted
Bundy's infamous methods were
incorporated into Bill's kidnapping
technique - he - were a fake cast to
feign disability then used said cast to
knock his victims out the third source
of dark inspiration for Buffalo Bill was
Gary Michael - a Philadelphia nurse who
had a penchant for kidnapping women and
shackling them in his basement these
three real killers alongside a few
others contribute to the terrifying
composite that is Buffalo Bill but he's
not the only character rooted in real
world figures Jack Crawford is based on
real-life criminal profiler John Douglas
who is also the inspiration behind the
Netflix series mine hunter Jodie Foster
also worked with FBI agent Mary Ann
Krause
who provided invaluable insight into
Clarisse starlings circumstances the
moment when Clarisse cries in the
privacy of her car after her first
encounter with dr. Lecter rang
particularly true for Kraus who says I
saw it and thought now that's like me
The Silence of the Lambs commands a
great deal of respect among movie fans
but it has also come under fire over the
years for its presentation of members of
the LGBTQ community
critics decry buffalo bill as a twisted
caricature of gay and transgender people
capable of doing real damage to a
vulnerable population caterpillar into
chrysalis or pupa beauty all Betty wants
to change Jonathan Demi has addressed
these criticisms saying Buffalo Bill
wasn't a gay character he was a
tormented man who hated himself and
wished he was a woman because that would
have made him as far away from himself
as he possibly could be unfortunately
this doesn't come across as clearly as
demi would have liked in the film
especially considering some of the
problematic language the movie uses to
talk about transgender people Ted Levine
agrees with Demi however saying here's a
guy who imagines himself with this kind
of feminine power you know this
spiritual kind of mother power serial
killers all pursue that feminine energy
that female persona they get both
masculinity and femininity wrapped into
someone and that's like perfection real
power and that's what gum is after the
Silence of the Lambs is pretty much as
dark and suspenseful as a film can get
so you can imagine that filming it might
not be a barrel of laughs
to keep spirits up in the midst of such
intensity games and pranks became the
norm on set as Brooke Smith who portrays
kidnapped Katherine Martin told People
magazine everything was a joke even
though she and Hopkins had no scenes
together he would often come up to her
in character as the fearsome Hannibal
Lecter and give her flowers and
chocolates the crew also made a board
game based on a blueprint of the set
that they called thumbs game the aim of
which was to save Katherine Jonathan
Demi liked to play pranks on his actors
including leading lady Jodie Foster one
memorable gag took place as Foster
filmed a now-deleted scene of Claire
picking up a rental car Dimmie had the
rental car agent really test Clarisse
about who she was before giving her the
keys demanding ID foster could not of
course provide being the consummate
professional she is foster didn't break
character until she realized what was
going on the movie poster for The
Silence of the Lambs prominently
features Clarice Starling space with her
mouth covered by the death's-head moth
that buffalo bill likes to insert into
his victims throats but only the most
eagle-eyed fans might have noticed the
skull on the moth isn't actually a skull
at all the image is lifted from
surrealist painter Salvador Dali's 1951
photo envelope test mores enveloped us
Moors or voluptuous death portrays a
human skull formed out of naked women's
bodies dolly posed to the left of the
women wearing a top hat and an intense
expression rounds out the piece
obviously for the Silence of the Lambs
poster Dolly was removed only the women
remained in an artful nod to Buffalo
Bills modus operandi while there isn't a
whole lot of Dolly's characteristic
surrealism in the Silence of the Lambs
in many ways Buffalo Bills project is a
horrible exercise and absurdity of dolly
s proportions you might think that
releasing a best-selling novel might
make any author happy especially when
it's turned into a widely beloved film
funnily enough though Silence of the
Lambs offered Thomas Harris has never
and will never watch the movie or any of
the many other adaptations of his work
that have graced the big and small
screens
Jonathan Demi has said this is because
Harris heard an anecdote about author
John Locke or a seeing an episode of the
BBC's adaptation of Smiley's people his
classic spy novel which featured Sir
Alec Guinness as his leading man
the Caray was so astounded by Genesis
performance that he came to consider
smiley as belonging to the actor instead
of him harris feared that seeing Hopkins
as Lecter would produce the same effect
loosening the character from his grasp
as an author this is despite the fact
that the Lecter of the books is
Lithuanian and has red eyes and a sixth
finger on his left hand but that's the
power of Anthony Hopkins for you like
his colleagues Scott Glenn did a great
deal of research when working on his
character FBI agent Jack Crawford
he spent a lot of time with John Douglas
the profiler on whom his character had
been based and Douglas didn't pull any
punches and showing Glenn the kinds of
things he'd seen in his long career as
Glenn told People magazine
I lost a certain degree of innocence to
this day I find myself having unpleasant
dreams about the things I found out in
fact Glenn's time at the FBI training
facility in Quantico was so profoundly
upsetting that he changed his political
stance from being against capital
punishment and now broadly agrees with
it as Glenn himself says the experience
in Quantico changed my mind about that
for all time a disgraced Clarice
Starling makes her second appearance in
the 2001 The Silence of the Lambs
follow-up Hannibal but Jodie Foster
elected not to return for the role and
Julianne Moore was cast instead this was
a smart move on Foster's part as
Hannibal ended up being one of the
weakest links in the Hannibal Lecter
franchise however in early 2020 CBS
announced its series commitment to a
dedicated Clarice Starling show entitled
Clarice that will take place one year
after the events of the Silence of the
Lambs Clarice is said to be a deep dive
into starlings career as a profiler of
serial killers as she simultaneously
navigates the sexism of the FBI but this
news shocked fans Brian Fuller's
arthouse horror series Hannibal which
was abruptly canceled after just three
seasons hopefully Clarice will satisfy
fans of the franchise with a searing
look into the life of The Silence of the
Lambs unforgettable heroine check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you
[Music]